>> THE CANDIDATES WHO RUN FOR
OFFICE AND THE FBI INVESTIGATORS
WHO DECIDE WHETHER TO PROSECUTE
THEM, THESE ARE THEIR STORIES.
♪
JOHN: TONIGHT, A POLITICAL NOIR
STARRING HILLARY CLINTON.
I AM IN CHARLOTTE, NORTH
CAROLINA, WHERE PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND HILLARY CLINTON MADE THEIR
DEBUT ON THE TRAIL.
MARK IS 160 MILES AWAY WITH
DONALD TRUMP, A COMPETING RALLY
LATER TONIGHT.
WE WILL HELP MARK WITH US LATER
IN THE SHOW.
FOR NOW, I'M JOINED BY AL HUNT.
THE CONTEXT FOR BOTH OF THESE
EVENTS WERE COMPLETELY AND
UTTERLY CHANGED BY THE BIGGER
NEWS THAT CAME OUT THIS MORNING,
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
ANNOUNCING THE END OF HIS
AGENCY'S INVESTIGATION INTO
CLINTON'S HANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
IN HIS PUBLIC REMARKS, HE
OFFERED A HARSH, THOROUGHGOING
CRITIQUE, BUT ALL TO LEAVE
CRIMINAL CHARGES BE FILED
AGAINST THE PRESENT THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
>> 110 E-MAILS IN 52 E-MAIL
CHAINS HAVE BEEN DETERMINED BY
THE AGENCY TO CONTAIN CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AT THE TIME THEY
WERE SENT OR RECEIVED.
EIGHT OF THOSE CHAINS CONTAINED
INFORMATION THAT WAS TOP SECRET,
ALTHOUGH WE DID NOT FIND CLEAR
EVIDENCE THAT SECRETARY CLINTON
OR HER COLLEAGUES INTENDED TO
VIOLATE LAWS GOVERNING THE
HANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT THEY WERE
EXTREMELY CARELESS IN THEIR
HANDLING OF VERY SENSITIVE,
HIGHLY CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
ALTHOUGH THERE IS EVIDENCE OF
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS OF THE
STATUTES REGARDING THE HANDLING
OF CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, OUR
JUDGMENT IS THAT NO PROSECUTOR
WOULD BRING A CASE.
WE ARE EXPRESSING OUR VIEW THAT
NO CHARGES ARE APPROPRIATE IN
THIS CASE.
JOHN: EVEN DOWN IN CHARLOTTE,
YOU COULD HEAR THE COLLECTIVE
SIGH OF RELIEF FROM CLINTON'S
BROOKLYN HEADQUARTERS.
"WE ARE GLAD THIS MATTER IS NOW
RESOLVED."
REPUBLICANS WERE PREDICTABLY
QUICK TO JUMP OVER THE DECISION,
QUESTIONING THE IMPARTIALITY OF
THE FBI'S PROBE.
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
RELEASES STATEMENT, "WHILE I
RESPECT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS OF THE FBI, THE
ANNOUNCEMENT DEFIES EXPLANATION.
NO ONE SHOULD BE ABOVE THE LAW."
CHARLES GRASSLEY CALLED ON THE
FBI TO MAKE ALL THE EVIDENCE
PUBLIC.
DONALD TRUMP, OF COURSE, TURNED
TO TWITTER, TWEETING, "FBI
DIRECTOR SAID CROOKED HILLARY
COMPROMISED OR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
NO CHARGES.
WOW."
HE ALSO TWEETED "THE SYSTEM IS
RIGGED.
GENERAL PETRONIUS GOT IN TROUBLE
FOR FAR LESS, VERY UNFAIR.
AS USUAL, BAD JUDGMENT."
WHAT HAPPENS NOW?
AL: HILLARY CLINTON HAS A SECOND
REASON TO UTTER A SIGH RELIEF
BECAUSE THESE REPUBLICANS ARE
PLAYING THIS SO STUPIDLY.
SHE WAS NOT ONLY CARELESS.
SHE WAS RECKLESS AND ARROGANT,
BUT RATHER THAN SEIZING ON THAT,
THEY'RE TRYING TO SUGGEST THERE
IS SOMETHING RIGGED HERE.
JAMES COMEY IS A MAN OF
INTEGRITY.
NO ONE COULD QUESTION HIS
JUDGMENT ON THIS.
I'M SHOCKED AT PAUL RYAN.
I'M NOT SHOCKED AT DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT THEY OUGHT TO DO IS SEES
WHAT IS OUT THERE.
IT IS DIFFERENT THAN DAVID
PORTRAY IS.
INTENT REALLY MATTERS HERE.
HE GAVE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
TO HIS MISTRESS.
IF THAT IS NOT INTENT, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS.
HILLARY CLINTON WAS ARROGANT AND
RECKLESS, AND THE GOP SHOULD BE
MAKING THAT CASE.
JOHN: I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
DIRECTOR, HE CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD
THE POLITICS OF THIS.
RATHER THAN LEADING WITH THIS,
HE GAVE HER POLITICAL OPPONENTS
ARE A LOT OF MATERIAL TO WORK
WITH.
I'M SURE WE WILL HEAR A LOT OF
IT FROM NOW UNTIL ELECTION DAY.
THE BOTTOM LINE, A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ASKED ME, HAD HE
THINK THIS PLACE FOR HILLARY
CLINTON?
TALKING TO HER SENIOR STAFF AND
MY OWN SENSE OF THIS, THIS IS A
SIMPLE STORY.
THE STORY IS BINARY, INDICTMENT
OR NO INDICTMENT.
IF HILLARY CLINTON WAS INDICTED,
THIS WOULD BE ONE OF THE WORST
DAYS IN HILLARY CLINTON'S LIFE.
SHE MIGHT NOT BE THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE OR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
TO DATE SHE HAS BASICALLY BEEN
EXONERATED IN THIS E-MAIL
SCANDAL, THIS E-MAIL
CONTROVERSY.
IT IS A GOOD DAY FOR HILLARY
CLINTON.
I KNOW THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
ARGUMENTS ABOUT WHAT SHE DID,
BUT SHE IS MORE OR LESS
POLITICALLY FREE AND CLEAR OF
THIS.
THERE HAS BEEN DAMAGE DONE, BUT
SHE IS FREE AND CLEAR.
DUELING TAR HEEL RALLIES TODAY.
AFTER GIVING A SPEECH TO THE
NATIONAL EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
TEACHERS UNION IN WASHINGTON,
CLINTON BOARDED AIR FORCE ONE TO
A STATE LOST NARROWLY IN 2012.
ON STAGE NOT FAR FROM WHERE I'M
SITTING AT THIS MOMENT, OBAMA
TOOK SOME JABS AT DONALD TRUMP
WHILE PRAISING CLINTON'S
EXPERIENCE AND, WELL LET'S TAKE
A LISTEN TO THAT SOUND CARD --
THAT SOUND.
♪
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, BUT
WE ARE FIRED UP AND READY TO GO,
READY TO WIN THIS ELECTION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
BARACK OBAMA.
>> HILLARY, HILLARY, HILLARY.
I HAVE HAD A FRONT ROW SEAT TO
HER JUDGMENT, HER TOUGHNESS, AND
COMMITMENT TO DIPLOMACY.
I WITNESSED IT IN THE SITUATION
ROOM, WHERE SHE ARGUED IN FAVOR
OF THE MISSION TO GET BIN LADEN.
I SAW HOW AS A FORMER SENATOR
FROM NEW YORK SHE KNEW, SHE
UNDERSTOOD, BECAUSE SHE HAD SEEN
IT.
SHE HAD WITNESSED IT, WHAT THIS
WOULD MEAN FOR THE THOUSANDS WHO
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES WHEN THE
TWIN TOWERS FAIL.
THIS IS NOT ENTERTAINMENT.
THIS IS REAL.
THIS IS NOT A REALITY SHOW.
THIS IS REALITY.
BEING PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES MEANS YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH REALITY.
BUT I AM HERE TODAY BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN HILLARY CLINTON.
I WANT YOU TO HELP ELECT HER TO
BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
JOHN: AL, WE ARE STILL WAITING
TO SEE DONALD TRUMP SO WE CAN'T
DO A SIDE-BY-SIDE COMPARISON OF
THESE TWO EVENTS.
I WAS IN THE ROOM.
YOU WATCHED IT ON TELEVISION,
WHICH IS HOW MOST PEOPLE WERE
EXPERIENCING THAT EVENT.
HOW FORMIDABLE DO YOU THINK THE
CLINTON-OBAMA TANDEM LOOKS
TODAY?
>> PRETTY DARN FERMENTABLE.
BILL CLINTON REALLY HELP BARACK
OBAMA IN NORMA SWEET IN 2012
WITH THAT CONVENTION SPEECH.
BOY WAS TODAY PAY BACK PLUS.
BARACK OBAMA AT A TIME WHEN
HILLARY CLINTON, YOU'RE RIGHT,
IT WAS A GREAT DAY THAT SHE
ESCAPED INDICTMENT, BUT HER
TRUST ISSUE IS A REAL PROBLEM
WITH VOTERS.
OBAMA IS NOW FAR MORE POPULAR
THAN CLINTON OR TRUNK.
I THINK HE HAS STANDING.
I THINK HE DID IT WELL TODAY.
IT LOOKED GOOD.
I KNOW DEMOCRATS THINK THAT THE
ONE MISTAKE OBAMA MADE IN 2012
WAS NOT CONTESTING NORTH
CAROLINA.
HE MIGHT HAVE WON IT AGAIN.
IF I HAD THAT THAT AS OF TODAY,
I WOULD PUT IT IN THE DEMOCRATIC
CATEGORY.
>> THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A HISTORIC
MOMENT AND DEMOCRATS HAVE WAITED
A LONG TIME, FIRST HAVING
NOMINATED AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
AND NOW ABOUT TO NOMINATE THE
FIRST WOMAN TO LEAD THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
TO SEE THE TWO OF THEM ON STAGE,
FORMER RIVALS, BITTER RIVALS IN
2008, THEN PARTNERS IN
STATECRAFT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION, NOW POLITICAL
ALLIES, THE CROWD WAS IN LOVE
WITH WHAT THEY SAW ON STAGE, AND
THE CLINTON PEOPLE WERE IN LOVE
WITH IT TOO.
SEEING THIS ON STAGE IN KNOWING
WE WILL SEE A LOT MORE OF IT,
KNOWING HOW MUCH PRESIDENT OBAMA
WANTS TO PROTECT HIS LEGACY AND
TAKE ON DONALD TRUMP AND THE
FACT THAT OBAMA IS A CONVERT TO
HER CAUSE.
THEY THINK THAT IS POWERFUL,
THAT HE WAS ONCE A CRITIC OF
HERS AND IS NOW A CONVERT.
THEY THINK THAT IS A POLITICAL
PLUS THAT HE CAN BRING TO THE
RACE, AND THEY SOLD THE FIRST
SIGN OF IT TODAY.
>> I WILL BET YOU PRIVATELY, AT
LEAST AMONG BILL AND HILLARY, IT
MUST RANKLE A LITTLE BIT.
THEY THINK THEY ARE THE GREAT
POLITICAL STRATEGIST AND
EVERYTHING OF ALL TIMES, AND
THEY NEED OBAMA.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY HE CAN
CARRY THEM.
THAT OLD THING ABOUT AN
EISENHOWER JACKET, THERE ARE NO
COATTAILS.
JOHN: SHE NEEDS THE ENTHUSIASM
OF DEMOCRATS, AND DEMOCRATS LOVE
BARACK OBAMA, AND THAT IS A HUGE
POLITICAL ASSET FOR HER.
WHEN WE COME BACK, MORE REACTION
TO THE FBI ANNOUNCEMENT, TEAM
TRUMP, AND A SUPPORTER.
THAT IS COMING UP RIGHT AFTER
THIS.
♪
JOHN: IT WAS, OF COURSE, AS WE
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING, A
MEGA-MONSTER-GIGANTIC,
GODZILLA-SIZE NEWSDAY FOR
HILLARY CLINTON.
WE ARE JOINED IN NEW YORK AND IN
HER HOME STUDIO.
I'M GOING TO START OFF WITH YOU
GUYS.
I ASK YOU THIS QUESTION, THERE
IS NO DOUBT AS I SAID EARLIER IN
THE SHOW, WHEN THE QUESTION IS
INDICTMENT VERSUS
NON-INDICTMENT, HILLARY CLINTON
IS THE BIG WINNER TODAY.
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL DOWNSIDE INTO THE WAY
THIS WAS ANNOUNCED, THE TIMING,
AND THE THINGS THAT HE SAID IN
THE PROCESS OF EXONERATING HER
FROM ANY CRIMINAL CHARGES?
>> I WOULD AGREE WITH YOUR
EARLIER CHARACTERIZATION
REGARDING CLINTON-OBAMA TEAM,
HOW FORMIDABLE THEY LOOK WEIRD I
THINK AL HUNT MADE THE COMMENT
AS WELL.
I THINK I SAW MARK EARLIER IN
THE DAY MAKE THE CASE THAT TO
YOUR QUESTION, JOHN, THAT
HE TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS HE THOUGHT ON THE PART OF
SECRETARY CLINTON AND SOME OF
HER TEAM, BUT A LOT OF THIS WILL
ERASE ITSELF, MEANING THE FOCUS
IN THE ATTENTION, AS MUCH AS MR.
TRUMP AND OTHERS MIGHT TRY TO
CONTINUE TO GIN IT UP.
IF BARACK OBAMA CONTINUES THIS
KIND OF CAMPAIGNING FOR
SECRETARY CLINTON AND ABLE TO
REASSEMBLE AND RECONSTITUTE THE
COALITION, PRESIDENT OBAMA BUILT
IT INTO THOUSAND EIGHT AND
STRENGTHEN IT IN 2012, IT IS
DIFFICULT FOR MR. TRUMP AND HIS
TEAM BECAUSE THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
THE COUNTRY CONTINUED TO MOVE IN
FAVOR OF DEMOCRATS AND MANY KEY
STATES, AND OF THAT TURNOUT
LEVEL IS THE SAME AS 2012, IT
BODES WELL FOR MRS. CLINTON.
MARK: KELLY AND, YOU ARE AN
ATTORNEY AND ADVISOR TO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WHAT IS THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
POSTURE TOWARDS WHAT HAS BEEN
SAID?
>> MR. TRUMP WILL SPEAK TO THAT.
WHERE AS HE REFUSED TO INDICT
HER, HE IN PURE AND HER.
HE AGREED WITH 67% OF THE
COUNTRY THAT SAYS SHE IS NEITHER
HONEST ARE TRUSTWORTHY.
-- OR TRUSTWORTHY.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE FBI WOULD DO
WHETHER I DECIDE TO CONTINUE TO
TRUST HER.
AMERICANS DON'T TRUST HER
BECAUSE SHE LIES FOR LIVING --
THEY BELIEVE SHE LIES FOR A
LIVING.
IN THEIR PEP RALLY DOWN IN NORTH
CAROLINA TODAY, NEITHER
PRESIDENT OBAMA NOR SECRETARY
CLINTON DID A VICTORY LAP ON THE
DECISION.
SHE DID NOT STAND UP AND SAY, I
HAVE BEEN VINDICATED.
SHE HAS BEEN VERY CAREFUL.
THE DIRECTOR'S WORDS WERE VERY
HARSH.
HE'S NOT RECOMMENDING
INDICTMENT, BUT SAID SHE WAS
EXTREMELY CARELESS.
HE SAID SHE AND THE PEOPLE WHO
WORSENING HER E-MAILS AND
RECEIVING HER E-MAILS ALL SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT HUNDREDS
OF E-MAILS, ALL SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN THAT THIS WAS WRONG.
JOHN: WHY NOT JUST MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT GOING FORWARD?
IS THAT THE ARGUMENT THAT THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER'S AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ARE GOING TO
MAKE?
OR ARE WE GOING TO HEAR FROM YOU
THAT IT IS A CONSPIRACY, THAT
SOMEHOW THIS IS PART OF A "RAKE
SYSTEM"?
>> THAT IS A LARGE PART OF WHAT
THIS ELECTION IS ABOUT.
ONE THING THAT WILL NOT CHANGE
BETWEEN NOW AND NOVEMBER IS THE
INSIDER-OUTSIDER
-ESTABLISHMENT-NONESTABLISHMENT
SET UP BETWEEN THESE TWO PEOPLE.
IN SOME WAYS, THIS PLAYS RIGHT
INTO MR. TRUMP'S ARGUMENT THAT
IT IS A RIGGED, CORRUPT SYSTEM
THAT ONLY BENEFITS INSIDERS.
I THINK THAT BILL CLINTON PUT
HIS WIFE AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
LYNCH IN A VERY BAD POSITION
LAST WEEK.
IT WASN'T LIKE THAT WAS ANCIENT
HISTORY.
I THINK FINALLY IT IS NOT GOING
TO ERASE THE FACT -- A FOX NEWS
POLL LAST WEEK SHOWED 58% THINK
HILLARY CLINTON IS CORRUPT.
I DON'T REMEMBER POLLSTERS
ASKING THE WORD CORRUPT.
MARK: IF SOMEONE DID WHAT
HILLARY CLINTON IS SAID TO BE
DONE AND APPLIED FOR A JOB AT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND
REQUIRED A SECURITY CLEARANCE,
COULD THEY GET IT?
>> I IMAGINE SO.
I HEARD MAYOR GIULIANI MADE THAT
COMMENT.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT AND ARE THE
STANDARD THAT WAS LAID OUT, SHE
DID NOT VIOLATE ANY STATUTES.
HE RECOMMENDED TO THE FBI, THE
FBI RECOMMENDED TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT NO ACTION BE
TAKEN.
HE SAID IN TERMS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE STEPS, SURE --
MARK: WE HAVE TO GO TO BREAK.
IF YOU WERE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
SOMEBODY APPLIED FOR A JOB THAT
INVOLVED NATIONAL SECURITY, THAT
WOULD NOT DISQUALIFY THEM IN
YOUR JUDGMENT?
>> WE WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A REAL
SERIOUS CONVERSATION, BUT, NO,
IT WOULD NOT DISQUALIFY THEM.
JOHN: STAY WITH THIS PIT WE WILL
PICK UP THIS CONVERSATION WHEN
WE COME BACK RIGHT AFTER THIS
BREAK.
♪
JOHN: WE ARE BACK.
YOU WATCHED AS YOU INDICATED
EARLIER THE CLINTON-OBAMA EVENT.
PUTTING ASIDE THE QUESTIONS OF
THE FBI, DID YOU SEE A
POLITICALLY POTENT TANDEM THERE
ON STAGE?
>> I THINK TODAY WAS A GREAT DAY
FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
HER POLITICAL CAREER AND
CANDIDACY COULD HAVE BEEN OVER
WITH AN INDICTMENT.
INSTEAD SHE WENT DOWN IN NORTH
CAROLINA ON AIR FORCE ONE AND
YOU AND I PAID FOR IT.
EVERY TIME YOU CAN HAVE A
TWO-TERM SITTING PRESIDENT SAY
TO VOTERS, GIVE ME A THIRD TERM.
RONALD REAGAN DID IT FOR HIS
VICE PRESIDENT, GEORGE BUSH.
IT'S NOT CLEAR THE WHOLE COUNTRY
WANTS A THIRD TERM OF BARACK
OBAMA, BUT WHEN HE WAS READING
FROM THE TELEPROMPTER, WHICH WAS
MOST OF THE TIME, IT WAS A GREAT
SOLID, STEADY CALL FOR HER TO BE
THE NEXT PRESIDENT, AND HE WAS
DISSING DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE HE
CAN'T HELP HIMSELF.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS UNFORTUNATE.
HE IS STILL THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HE HAS EVERY RIGHT TO ENDORSE
AND CAMPAIGN WITH HER, BUT THERE
IS A LINE THAT SHOULD NOT BE
CROSSED.
I LISTEN TO GARDEN-VARIETY
PUNDITS ALL DAY LONG INSULT
DONALD TRUMP, AND THEY SEEM
PRETTY PATTY, SO I WOULD EXPECT
SOMETHING DIFFERENT HERE.
>> MR. TRUMP HAS PERSONALLY
ATTACKED THE PRESIDENT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
HE STILL HAS NOT PUT OUT THE
FIRE YET THAT HE DOESN'T BELIEVE
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS BORN IN
THE UNITED STATES.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A FORMIDABLE
PIECE, AND IF I WERE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THIS EQUATION, THE
BIGGEST WORRY I WOULD HAVE IS
THAT THE TWO OF THEM WITH THEIR
SUPPORTERS CAN REASSEMBLE AND
RECONSTITUTE THAT UNBELIEVABLE
COALITION THAT MR. OBAMA PUT
TOGETHER FOR YEARS AGO NOW.
MARK: THE REASON DONALD TRUMP IS
HERE TODAY IS NOT A COINCIDENCE.
HE CHANGE THINGS UP TO TRY TO
STEP ON THE OBAMA-CLINTON
CAMPAIGNING.
EXPLAIN THE LOGIC OF COMING TO
THE SAME STATE AND WHAT HIS
MESSAGE WILL BE TONIGHT?
>> PERHAPS, MARK, ONE OF THE
GREATEST ASSETS OF DONALD TRUMP
TO THE ELECTORATE HAS BEEN THAT
HE IS UNAPOLOGETICALLY UNAFRAID
OF THE CLINTON CANDIDACY.
THAT IS REFRESHING.
WE HAVE HAD REPUBLICAN NOMINEES
PULL THEIR PUNCHES ON ANY NUMBER
OF THINGS, SO HE IS SAYING I AM
NOT GIVING YOU ONE OF THE
SWING STATES IN NORTH CAROLINA.
IT IS A MARGINAL RED-BLUE STATE.
IT COULD GO EITHER WAY.
BARACK OBAMA WON IT IN 2008.
HE WILL MAKE THE CASE AGAINST
HILLARY CLINTON.
TODAY, HE CAN QUOTE RIGHT FROM
THE PRESS CONFERENCE.
I THINK IF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
RUNS ADS QUOTING WHERE IT
LITERALLY SAYS THAT SHE WAS
RECKLESS, CARELESS, SO I THINK
HE IS TELLING THE PEOPLE OF
NORTH CAROLINA THERE WE WILL BE
BACK HERE AGAIN AND AGAIN TO
MAKE THE STAY COMPETITIVE.
JOHN: HILLARY CLINTON LAST WEEK
WITH SENATOR WARREN AND TODAY
WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA, LATER WITH
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
IS THERE ANY RISK OF IT SHE
STARTS TO LOOK A LITTLE
UNINSPIRING NEXT TO SUCH A HEAVY
HITTING LINEUP?
>> NO, I THINK IT REINFORCES FOR
VOTERS, THE PARTY, AND
INDEPENDENCE, THE DIVERSITY AND
STRENGTH OF THE PARTY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A PRESIDENT
HILLARY CLINTON IN THE WHITE
HOUSE WITH WHOEVER SHE CHOOSES
TO BE VP, COMBINE IT WITH A
FORMIDABLE TEAM IN THE U.S.
SENATE, IT SIGNALS TO THE
COUNTRY THAT HERE IS A PRESIDENT
THAT CAN WORK WITH CONGRESS AND
GET THINGS DONE.
YOU HAVE EVEN HEARD REPUBLICAN
SENATORS PRIVATELY SAY THEY
COULD WORK WITH HER ON
FOREIGN-POLICY ISSUES, ECONOMIC
POLICY ISSUES.
EVEN TODAY WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA,
SHE OPENED WITH A LOT OF
ELECTRICITY, EXCITEMENT, AND
SUBSTANCE.
WE HEARD THE PRESIDENT
UNDERSCORE HOW SMART SHE IS.
I THINK IT ONLY AMPLIFIES THE
POINT MORE THAT SHE IS NOT ONLY
READY, BUT READY TO WORK WITH
CONGRESS.
>> TODAY MAY BE HER BEST DAY
WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA ON THE
TRAIL.
SHE WILL BE DIMINISHED UNDER THE
BRIGHTER STAR POWER OF PRESIDENT
BARACK OBAMA.
THE OTHER RISK IS WE ALL KNOW
THAT COOL IS NOT TRANSFERABLE,
SO HER PROBLEMS ARE LIKABILITY
AND TRUSTWORTHINESS.
YOU CAN'T IMPUTE THAT TO SOMEONE
ELSE.
HE WOULD DO A GREAT JOB MUCH
LIKE BILL CLINTON DID AT THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL CONVENTION
IN CHARLOTTE, BUT SHE RUNS THE
RISK OF LOOKING LIKE SHE NEEDS
TO BE PROPPED UP, THAT SHE CAN'T
DO THIS ON HER OWN.
MARK: WE HAVE LESS THAN 30
SECONDS.
YOU THOUGHT TOM COTTON WAS
DONALD TRUMP'S BEST VICE
PRESIDENT OF CHOICE.
>> I LOVE THE LIST.
THE SHORT LIST IS GROWING,
REALLY SERIOUS, FORMIDABLE
PEOPLE.
I THINK HE HAS A VERY STRONG
LIST TO CHOOSE FROM.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT HE IS
MEETING WITH THEM ONE-ON-ONE AND
BEING VERY HONEST ABOUT WHO IS
BEING CONSIDERED.
IT ALSO SHOWS THE UNIFYING OF
THE PARTY THAT IS OFTEN NOT
MENTION ENOUGH IN THE PRESS.
JOHN: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SORRY TO CUT YOU OFF THERE.
COMING UP, OUR TAKES ON THE VICE
PRESIDENTIAL SWEEPSTAKES RIGHT
AFTER THIS.
♪
>> WELCOME BACK.
THERE ARE ONLY A FEW DAYS LEFT
TO TINKER WITH YOUR 2016 FANTASY
LEAGUE PRESIDENTIAL LINEUP AND
BASEBALL LINEUP AND ALL YOUR
FANTASY LEAGUE LINEUPS.
THIS IS THE FINAL STRETCH OF THE
VEEPSTAKES SEASON.
WE'RE SEEING ACTION FROM
POTENTIAL RUNNING MATES.
LET'S START WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
A HANDFUL, HILLARY CLINTON'S
POSSIBLE NUMBER TWOS, INCLUDING
SENATORS SHERROD BROWN OF OHIO
AND PEREZ.
THEY WERE ALL DISHING OUT
CLINTON TALKING POINTS, WHILE
DODGING QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
THEY WOULD JOIN THE TICKET WITH
HILLARY CLINTON.
MARK, WHERE DO THINGS STAND AT
THIS MOMENT WITH HILLARY
CLINTON'S RUNNING MATE DECISION?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHO SHE IS
ACTUALLY PLANNING TO PICK.
BUT I WILL SAY, FROM TALKING TO
CLINTON PEOPLE, ABOUT HALF THE
PEOPLE ARE IN TOUCH WITH HER
ABOUT THIS.
ABOUT HALF AREN'T.
THEY'RE VERY HAPPY WITH THE
CHOICES.
NO ONE IS GOING TO MAKE THE
CHOICE THAT HER CHOICES ARE
GOING TO REVOLUTIONIZE THE RACE.
THE TWO NAMES I HEAR THE MOST
ARE THE LABOR SECTOR AND TIM
CAIN, THE SENATOR FROM VIRGINIA.
PEOPLE SEEM GENUINELY HAPPY WITH
THOSE.
THEY'D BE PERFECTLY SATISFIED.
MY SENSE IS THAT THEY DON'T
THINK SHE'S HEADED TOWARDS A
SURPRISE.
THE PERSON SHE THINKS -- I STILL
THINK SHE WON'T PICK UNTIL TRUMP
DOES.
THAT MEANS MAYBE NOT UNTIL AFTER
HIS CONVENTION, SINCE HE MAY
WELL PICK ON THE EVE OF HIS
CONVENTION.
>> RIGHT.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS HERE, IS THE QUESTION
OF TIMING, WHEN DOES TRUMP PICK?
IF IT'S TRUE THAT TRUMP PICKS
NEXT WEEK, AS IS BEING
SUGGESTED, THAT WILL GIVE
CLINTON TIME THROUGH THE
REPUBLICAN CONVENTION AND INTO
THE TIME FROM WHEN SHE'D
ANNOUNCE, WHICH WOULD LIKELY BE
ON THE FRIDAY OR SATURDAY AFTER
THE REPUBLICAN CONVENTION AND
TRY TO STEP ON HIS HEADLINES.
I HEAR THOSE NAMES TOO.
CERTAINLY I HEAR TIM CANE A LOT
MORE THAN TOM PEREZ.
TOM PEREZ SOMEONE WHO SEEMS TO
BE SOMEONE WHO THEY WANT TO SEEM
IS IN CONSIDERATION RATHER THAN
SOMEONE WHO IS ACTUALLY IN
CONSIDERATION.
I STILL THINK TIM CANE IS THE
FRONT-RUNNER AND I STILL THINK
ELIZABETH WARREN MIGHT BE THE
BEST CHOICE.
>> THE OTHER THING, THE NAME WAS
RAISED, THE AGRICULTURAL SECTOR.
I THOUGHT -- SECRETARY.
I THOUGHT THAT'S WHO SHE WAS
GOING TO PICK.
HE PICKED -- I WOULD SAY HE'S AS
EXCITING AS TIM CAIN.
HE FITS A GOVERNING PARTNER,
SOMEONE WHO PEOPLE WOULD SAY IS
QUALIFIED, SOMEONE SHE'D LIKE TO
WORK WITH, SOMEONE WHO WILL BE
LOYAL TO HER.
BUT I'M NOT HEARING THAT
NECESSARILY AS...
>> SAME HERE.
>> IT SEEMS HARD FOR ME TO
BELIEVE THAT BILL WILL END UP ON
THE TICKET, BUT MAYBE WE'LL BE
SURPRISED BY THAT.
TURNING NOW TO THE QUESTION OF
DONALD TRUMP, BILLIONAIRE AND
PRESUMPTIVE REPUBLICAN NOMINEE,
AT HIS NEW JERSEY GOLF CLUB THIS
HOLIDAY WEEKEND.
TRUMP MET WITH TWO POSSIBLE
RUNNING MATES, WHO UNTIL
RECENTLY HAVE NOT BEEN WIDELY
SPECULATED ABOUT.
THAT WOULD BE MIKE PENCE, WHO
HUDDLED WITH TRUMP ON SATURDAY,
AND IOWA SENATOR JOANIE ERNST.
TOMORROW WE HAVE NEWT GINGRICH
REPORTEDLY CAMPAIGNING WITH THE
DONALD.
AND SENATOR BOB CORKER FROM
TENNESSEE.
WHERE DOES TRUMP'S RUNNING MATE
DECISION STAND IN YOUR MIND?
>> WELL, LOOK, ONE OF THE
FUNNIEST THINGS I'VE EVER HEARD
SOMEONE FROM THE CAMPAIGN SAY
ABOUT VEEPSTAKES WAS KELLYANNE
CONWAY.
THE SHORT LIST IS GETTING LONGER
AND ACTED AS IF THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
DOWN TO A HANDFUL OF CHOICES AND
THEN SAYING, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THESE CHOICES MAY NOT BE GOOD
ENOUGH.
EXPANDING TO PENCE, TO ERNST.
I BELIEVE THE NEW AIDS WHO HAVE
COME IN, IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS,
LOOKED AT THE LIST THAT TRUMP
WAS HONING IN ON AND SAID, NO,
NO ONE ON THAT LIST IS ACTUALLY
RIGHT.
YOU NEED TO THINK MORE BROADLY.
I DOUBT THAT HE WOULD -- IT
SOUNDS LIKE MAYBE THEY DID.
I THINK PENCE MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE, CONSIDERING THE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES.
>> WELL, HE'S GOT TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THAT HE HAS RIGHT NOW.
THE BIG PROBLEM HE HAS, WHICH IS
GETTING THE REPUBLICANS BASE,
REPUBLICANS TO COME HOME.
AND PENCE MIGHT BE AS GOOD A
SOLUTION ON THAT FRONT AS ANY
SOLUTION.
I THINK THAT'S THE BEST ARGUMENT
NOW AGAINST PUTTING CHRIS
CHRISTIE ON THE TICKET, SOMEONE
WHO I THINK TEMPERAMENTALLY
TRUMP IS ATTRACTED TO.
BUT CHRISTIE DOESN'T SOLVE THE
PROBLEM OF GETTING REPUBLICANS
TO COME HOME TO DONALD TRUMP.
I KNOW THE CLINTON PEOPLE, SOME
I TALKED TO, THEY STILL THINK
TRUMP WILL GO WITH HIS GUT IN
THE END.
NOW, THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON
INTERNALLY BUT THEY SUSPECT IT
WILL BE CHRISTIE OR GINGRICH.
DEMOCRATS DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
REPUBLICANS IN GENERAL AND ABOUT
TRUMP IN PARTICULAR.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW THIS FOR A FACT.
BUT I HAVE ONE SOURCE SUGGESTING
TO ME THAT HE'S BEEN TALKED OUT
OF GINGRICH, THAT THEY'LL FIND
ANOTHER ROLE FOR GINGRICH IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT MAY WELL
BE A DEAD LETTER.
BUT EVERYBODY SAYS IN THE END,
THIS IS TRUMP'S DECISION.
TRUMP MAY JUST GO WITH THIS GUY.
THAT COULD MEAN ANYBODY.
AND THE YOUNG LAWYERS AND OLDER
LAWYERS WORKING WITH HIM, THEY
ARE -- JUST LIKE WITH PALIN, TO
VET SOMEBODY IN A BIG HURRY,
UNDER TIME PRESSURE IN THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED EIGHT
YEARS AGO.
IT WAS ANOTHER ROCKY WEEKEND FOR
TRUMP.
YOU'D THINK THAT HILLARY
CLINTON'S INTERVIEW AT THE
F.B.I. HEADQUARTERS WOULD HAVE
DOMINATED THE 4TH OF JULY
HOLIDAY WEEKEND.
INSTEAD WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT
THAT TWEET THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN SENT OUT, WITH WHAT
SEEMED TO BE AN IMAGE OF THE
STAR OF DAVID.
SOME SAID TO THE CONTRARY, IT
MAY BE A SHERIFF'S BADGE.
IN CASE YOUR BARBECUE GRILL
DIDN'T GIVE YOU ANY NEWS
UPDATES, HERE'S A QUICK
REFRESHER.
>> DONALD TRUMP, STAR OF DAVID.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
SATURDAY, TRUMP TWEETS IMAGE OF
HILLARY CLINTON, A PILE OF MONEY
AND A RED STAR.
>> MANY WOULD SAY THAT RESEMBLES
THE STAR OF DAVID.
>> IT'S IMMEDIATELY CALLED
ANTI-SEMITIC.
>> THE IMAGINE POSTED ON A WHITE
SUPREMACIST BOARD.
>> THEN IT'S DELETED.
THEN IT'S REPLACED BY A CIRCLE.
WAIT.
THAT CIRCLE.
>> THE POINTS OF THE STAR WERE
STILL VISIBLE!
>> A FIRESTORM OF CONTROVERSY.
>> ON MONDAY, TRUMP TWEETS IT
WAS A SHERIFF'S STAR.
THE RESPONSE, WHY DID YOU DELETE
IT IF IT WASN'T AN ISSUE?
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN SAYS CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN IS TRYING TO DIVERT
ATTENTION FROM HER ISSUE.
>> NOT EVERY STAR IS A STAR OF
DAVID.
>> THIS IS A SIMPLE STAR.
>> THIS HAND WRINGING GOING OVER
A GEOMETRIC SHAPE IS REALLY OUT
OF HAND.
>> IT'S THE STAR OF DAVID, OVER
$100 BILLS.
THIS IS NOT GEOMETRY.
IT'S IMAGERY, WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANT TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> ON TO THE NEXT PEOPLE.
>> AND IT'S HURTFUL TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
BUT I DO THINK, TO PLAY
VEEPSTAKES WITH YOU...
>> SO, MARK, GIVEN THE MOMENTOUS
CLINTON NEWS, IS THIS TRUMP
TWEET CONTROVERSY OVER BASICALLY
OR WILL IT LINGER SOMEHOW?
>> I THINK IT'S OVER, BECAUSE OF
THE COMEY NEWS AND BECAUSE OF
VEEPSTAKES AND THE CONVENTIONS
ARE COMING.
BUT I DO THINK, ONCE AGAIN,
TRUMP HAS GOT TO PROVE HIMSELF
AND HIS OPERATIONS, PROVE
HIMSELF TOP REPUBLICANS.
HE CAN'T LET A STORY LIKE THIS
FESTER.
IF YOU THINK IT'S UNFAIR, IF YOU
THINK THE PRESS IS OUT TO GET
YOU, WHATEVER, YOU JUST CAN'T
LET A STORY LIKE THIS FESTER.
I THINK HE'S OFF THE HOOK FOR
THIS ONE, IN TERMS OF DOMINATING
THE NEWS, BUT HE DOES HAVE TO
PROVE HIMSELF THAT HE WON'T LET
THESE KINDS OF THINGS HAPPEN.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A DAY TO WASTE.
>> THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS TWEETED
THINGS THAT HAVE THEIR ORIGINS
IN THE NASTIEST, MOST DISGUSTING
CORNERS OF THE UNIVERSE AND
TWITTER.
IT'S LIKE THE SIXTH TIME THAT
THE IMAGE HAS BEEN SOURCED TO
SOME WHITE SUPREMACIST,
ANTI-SEMITIC, RACIST TWEET
TWITTER ACCOUNT.
HE'S GOTTA CUT IT OUT!
HE'S GOTTA STOP IT, BECAUSE IF
HE KEEPS DOING IT, PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT HE'S PLAYING WITH FIRE,
TRYING TO RILE UP PARTS OF THE
REPUBLICAN BASE THAT ARE THE
UGLIEST PARTS OF IT.
AND IF TRUMP CONSTITUTE WANT
THAT IM-- DOESN'T WANT THAT
IMPRESSION, HE JUST NEEDS TO
STOP.
>> AND EVEN IF HE WAS AN -- IF
IT WAS AN ABSOLUTE ACTION, HE
STILL SHOULD TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APOLOGIZE, TO BE
INDIGNANT NOT ABOUT HILLARY
CLINTON BUT TO BE INDIGNANT
ABOUT THE GROUPS WHO HE'S BEING
ASSOCIATED WITH.
THAT LACK OF INDIGNATION IS
HURTING HIM WITH REPUBLICANS AS
WELL AS DEMOCRATS, NO DOUBT IN
MY MIND.
>> 100%.
THE ANTIDEFAMATION LEAGUE SAID
DONALD TRUMP HAS HAD NO PROBLEM
DENOUNCING PEOPLE HE DISAGREES
WITH IN THE MOST CLEAR AND
UNEQUIVOCAL TERMS.
HE SHOULD BE DENOUNCING THESE
KINDS OF PEOPLE AND THESE KINDS
OF WEBSITE AND TWITTER ACCOUNTS
WITH THE SAME KIND OF CLARITY.
ALL RIGHT.
COMING UP, OUR GOOD FRIEND, AL
HUNT, COMES BACK ON THE SHOW AND
WEIGHS IN ON WHY HE SAYS THE
F.B.I. WAS RIGHT TO NOT
RECOMMEND CRIMINAL CHARGES
AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT IS NEXT.
♪
>> WE ARE JOINED FROM
WASHINGTON, BY OUR GREAT FRIEND.
MR. HUNT WROTE A COLUMN TODAY
ENTITLED "HILLARY CLINTON NEEDS
A DR. NO."
AS I READ YOUR COLUMN, BRILLIANT
AS ALWAYS, IT SAID COMEY MADE
THE RIGHT DECISION BUT HILLARY
CLINTON NEEDS HELP.
WHAT KIND OF HELP DOES HILLARY
CLINTON NEED?
>> SHE NEEDS SOMEONE TO SAY
MRS. CLINTON OR MADAM SECRETARY,
YOU CAN'T DO THIS.
SHE SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THE
E-MAIL SERVER.
SOMEONE SHOULD HAVE TOLD HER
THAT, BACK IN 2009.
SOMEONE SHOULD HAVE TOLD HER,
JOHN, I'M SORRY, FINE IF YOU
WANT TO GIVE SPEECHES BUT YOU'RE
A VERY RICH PERSON.
DON'T TAKE $275 GRAND FROM
GOLDMAN SATCHS.
THE CLINTONS HAVE A LOT OF
TALENTS.
I THINK IN A TIME OF CRISIS, YOU
WOULD FEEL PRETTY GOOD ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON.
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE A SENSE OF
ENTITLEMENT AND ARROGANCE.
WE'RE SOMEHOW GOOD PEOPLE, SO
THE SAME RULES DON'T APPLY TO
US.
SHE NEEDS SOMEONE TO TELL HER,
NO, THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
>> IN THE CONTEXT OF GOING
FORWARD, WHY SHOULDN'T THAT
PERSON BE SOMEONE YOU KNOW WELL?
>> I THINK JOHN IS THE ONE WHO
BEST QUALIFIES FOR IT.
HE WAS IN THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
BUT KIND OF -- YOU KNOW, A
CAUTIONARY FLAG THERE, MARK,
WHICH I WROTE ABOUT IN THAT
COLUMN.
JOHN LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE
EARLY MORNING OF JANUARY 20,
2001, CONVINCED THAT HE HAD
PERSUADED BILL CLINTON, DON'T
PARDON MARK RICH, A SLEAZY
FUGITIVE.
AND POOR JOHN GOT BACK AFTER A
FEW HOURS OF SLEEP AND FOUND OUT
THAT CLINTON HAD PARDONED MARK
RICHT.
>> AL, IN HILLARY CLINTON'S
OPERATION OF THIS CAMPAIGN NOW,
IS IT POSSIBLE TO PUT SOMEONE IN
THAT ROLE?
HOW WOULD IT ACTUALLY BE
ENACTED?
>> WELL, I THINK I'M THINKING
MORE OF A PRESIDENCY, IF SHE
SHOULD WIN.
JOHN IS AN ADULT.
I THINK HE CAN DO THAT IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
THESE OTHER INCIDENTS OCCURRED
BEFORE THE CAMPAIGN.
I THINK SHE'S MADE MISTAKES BUT
NOTHING QUITE OF THAT EGREGIOUS
NATURE.
BUT WHEN SHE GETS TO BE
PRESIDENT, SHE'S GOT A LOT OF
SMART PEOPLE AROUND HER, BUT
MOST TEND TO BE REAL HILLARY
LOYALIST.
IT'S NOT THAT YOU WANT PEOPLE
AROUND YOU WHO AREN'T LOYAL BUT
YOU WANT SOMEONE AROUND YOU,
WHO, AS I SAID, WILL SAY NO.
I WAS CORRESPONDING TODAY.
WE SAID TED KENNEDY SAID ONE
TIME THAT PRESIDENT KENNEDY SAID
TO HIM YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE TWO OR
THREE SONS OF BITCHES AROUND
YOU.
THEN YOU HAVE TO REWARD THEM AND
LET THEM KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU
NEED.
THAT'S WHAT SHE NEEDS.
>> I'M APPARENTLY A VERY LUCKY
MAN BECAUSE I HAVE WAY MORE THAN
TWO OR THREE SONS OF BITCHES
AROUND ME AT ALL TIMES.
MY QUESTION FOR YOU IS, YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE DR. NO THAT
SHE NEEDS.
RIGHT NOW SHE'S RECRUITING A
DR. YES.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE VEEPSTAKES.
WHO DO YOU THINK MAKES SENSE FOR
HILLARY AS A RUNNING MATE?
>> I DON'T THINK TOM PEREZ DOES.
I DON'T THINK THE IDEA OF AN
UNELECTED PERSON SHOULD EVER BE
A RUNNING MATE, A GOOD A LABOR
SECRETARY AS HE MIGHT BE.
I THINK THE ONE THAT MAKES THE
MOST SENSE IS TIM KAINE, UNLESS
SHE THINKS SHE'S IN POLITICAL
TROUBLE.
THEN I THINK YOU HAVE TO GO TO
ELIZABETH WARREN.
I DON'T THINK THEY WANT TO PICK
A SHERROD BROWN.
>> YOU'VE BEEN WRITING A LOT OF
COLUMNS LATELY.
I REMEMBER ONE RECENT ONE WHERE
YOU TOOK TO TASK THE SANDERS
SUPPORTERS.
TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT.
>> YOU CAN SAY THERE'S A BETTER
CHOICE THAN TIM KAINE.
THE TWO CRITERIA OUGHT TO BE,
CAN THE PERSON BE PRESIDENT, AND
NUMBER TWO, IS THE PRESIDENT
COMFORTABLE WITH THEM IN A
CAMPAIGN SENSE AND PARTICULARLY
IN GOVERNING?
TIM KAINE CLEARLY MEETS THOSE
TESTS.
SHE MAY DECIDE SOMEONE IS
BETTER.
BUT TO SAY THAT TIM KAINE IS OUT
OF BOUNDS, THAT THIS IS A GUY
WHO HAS A 90% VOTING RECORD, HAS
BEEN A COMMITTED LIBERAL BY
VIRGINIA STANDARDS, CERTAINLY
AND EVEN BY NATIONAL STANDARDS,
THAT HE'S UNACCEPTABLE, I THINK
WOULD REALLY CREATE A CRAZY
CAUCUS WITHIN THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY, WHICH WAS WHAT WE USED TO
SEE SOME YEARS AGO, JOHN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AL, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
TWICE ON THIS SHOW TODAY.
IT'S ALWAYS A PLEASURE.
UP NEXT, WHAT TO EXPECT FROM
DONALD TRUMP'S NORTH CAROLINA
RALLY TONIGHT.
MARK WILL TALK ABOUT THAT WHEN
WE COME BACK.
>> WELCOME BACK.
WE'RE WAITING FOR DONALD TRUMP
TO ARRIVE FOR HIS FIRST PUBLIC
EVENT.
HE'S GOING TO APPEAR TODAY WITH
A SPECIAL GUEST.
JOINING ME HERE TO TALK ABOUT
THE SPECIAL GUEST --
>> ANOTHER SPECIAL GUEST.
>> SENATOR COKER, WHO WE THINK
IS ON THE LIST.
HE'S GOING TO BE CAMPAIGNING
WITH NEWT GINGRICH.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THESE
SEEMING AUDITIONS?
>> THIS IS A VERY PUBLIC TRYOUT.
[CHEERING]
[INAUDIBLE]
>> IT'S NOT ONLY HOW HE
INTERACTS WITH THESE POTENTIAL
V.P.'S BUT HOW THE PUBLIC TAKES
THEM.
HOW DOES THIS CROWD REACT TO BOB
CORKER?
ARE THEY AS ENTHUSIASTIC FOR HIM
AS THEY ARE FOR DONALD TRUMP?
ALSO, NEWT GINGRICH, IS THE
CROWD AS EXCITED FOR NEWT
GINGRICH AS THEY ARE FOR DONALD
TRUMP?
I THINK THAT NEWT GINGRICH IS
ABLE TO WHIP UP THE CROWD.
GOVERNOR PENCE, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO SEE.
HE'S OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
WITH HIM.
BUT THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED.
USUALLY THESE ARE VERY CIRCLE
THE WAGONS CLOSED-DOOR MEETINGS.
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT
TRUMP IS A GREAT PERFORMER.
HE KNOWS HOW TO GET A GREAT
REACTION FROM THE CROWD.
I BET HE WATCHES, DO THEY MOVE
THE CROWD?
BECAUSE THAT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PART OF HOW HE'S BEEN A
CANDIDATE.
>> I THINK, WHO IS GOING TO HELP
YOU?
WHO IS GOING TO HELP YOU WITH A
CERTAIN DEMOGRAPHIC?
I'M NOT SURE THAT'S THE CORRECT
WAY TO LOOK AT THINGS, BUT
DONALD TRUMP HAS DEFIED ALL
EXPECTATIONS.
I THINK WHAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING FOR IS
PERSONALITY-BASED.
DOES THE CHARACTER MATCH?
ALSO, IS HE SOMEBODY THAT'S
GOING TO PLAY THE ROLE THAT
DONALD TRUMP WANTS HIM TO PLAY,
IF THEY GET INTO THE WHITE
HOUSE?
AND WHAT I'VE BEEN HEARING IS
THAT DONALD TRUMP WILL...
[CHEERING]
[INAUDIBLE]
>> BEYOND THE TWEETS TRUMP PUT
OUT IN REACTION TO THE COMEY
ANNOUNCEMENT, THERE WAS A LOT OF
PRESS RELEASE.
YOU READ THROUGH THEM.
WHAT'S KIND OF THE MESSAGE THERE
FROM THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
>> RIGGED SYSTEM.
THAT'S THE NARRATIVE THEY'VE
BEEN TRYING TO PAINT IN THIS
CAMPAIGN NOW.
BUT THEY STARTED FOCUSING IN ON
IT IN THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS,
SAYING THAT NOT ONLY WAS IT HARD
FOR HIM TO GET THE NOMINATION,
BECAUSE IT'S A RIGGED SYSTEM,
AND THAT INOCULATES HIM FROM THE
IDEA OF THE DELEGATES TAKING THE
NOMINATION AWAY FROM HIM.
BUT ALSO --
>> WE'RE GOING TO THROW IT BACK
TO YOU, BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING
THE PLEDGE HERE.
>> THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> ONE MORE THING BEFORE WE GO.
WE COULDN'T HELP NOTICING
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S MANY FACES
WHILE HE WAS SITTING BEHIND
HILLARY CLINTON ON STAGE AT THAT
RALLY, HERE IN CHARLOTTE.
I WAS KIND OF AMAZED BY THEM.
IN CASE YOU MISSED IT, DON'T
WORRY.
WE'VE CATALOGED SOME OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL FACIAL EXPRESSIONS
ON DISPLAY.
[CHEERING]
♪[MUSIC]♪
>> MAN, I LOVE THOSE THINGS WHEN
WE DO THEM!
KIND OF FANTASTIC.
MARK, I WANT TO COME BACK TO THE
BIG NEWS OF THE DAY.
COMEY.
NOBODY EXPECTED IT.
NOBODY IN CLINTON WORLD EXPECTED
IT TODAY.
WHAT'S YOUR VIEW ABOUT ITS
IMPACT AND WHAT HAPPENS NOW IN
THE AFTERMATH?
>> WELL, WHAT COMEY DID WAS
EXTRAORDINARY.
AND I UNDERSTAND WHY HE DID IT.
HE FELT, GIVEN THE PUBLIC'S
SCRUTINY, PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT
OF WHAT LORETTA LYNCH DID, HE
NEEDED TO HAVE SOME TRABS
TRANSPARENCY.
BUT IT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY STEP
FOR AN F.B.I. DIRECTOR TO LAY
OUT THE FACT OF A CASE -- FACTS
OF A CASE LIKE THAT AND THEN
EXONERATE HER.
I THINK HE IS NOW GOING TO HAVE
TO EXPLAIN MORE, AND I THINK
PEOPLE WILL DIG INTO SOME OF THE
THINGS HE REVEALED.
HE REVEALED NEW THINGS TODAY
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON'S E-MAIL
PRACTICES THAT EITHER WEREN'T
KNOWN AT ALL OR WEREN'T
AFFIRMED.
BUT IN THE MAIN, NOT BEING
INDICTED IS OBVIOUSLY A HUGE
POLITICAL THING FOR HER.
I THINK, IN A WEIRD WAY, COMEY
LAYING IT OUT, SAYING I'M A MAN
OF INTEGRITY, YET I STILL DIDN'T
WANT TO INDICT HER, IN A WEIRD
WAY, I THINK THAT HELPS HER.
IF THEY GET A FEW BREAKS, I
THINK THIS THING MAY BE BEHIND
HER AND REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO LOOK ELSEWHERE.
>> I COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
I THINK PEOPLE FROM THE CLINTON
OFFICIALS I TALKED TO, THEY SEE
IT THAT WAY.
THEY -- OBVIOUSLY THEIR FIRST
THICK WAS, WE'RE NOT INDICTED.
THAT'S GREAT.
THE SECOND THING WAS, YOU KNOW,
HAVING COMEY TAKE HER TO THE
WOODSHED, OF COURSE IT GIVES
SOME REPUBLICANS SOME AMMUNITION
TO FIRE AT HER.
BUT IT DOES RAISE COMEY UP IN
SOME WAYS.
THEY CAN SAY, LOOK, COMEY DIDN'T
GO LIGHT ON US.
HE DIDN'T SEEM LIKE HE WAS
UNWILLING TO RECOMMEND AN
INDICTMENT.
BUT HE STILL DIDN'T INDICT.
>> IF HE HAD JUST DONE WHAT
WOULD NORMALLY BE DONE, WHICH IS
NOT SAY ANYTHING, AND JUST LIKE
CLINTON'S LAWYERS SAY, SHE'S NOT
INDICTED, PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
WONDERED, WHAT DID THEY LOOK AT?
WAS THERE A POLITICAL INFLUENCE?
WHAT STANDARDS DID HE USE?
COMEY LAID IT OUT.
I THINK IT'S UNPRECEDENTED,
CERTAINLY WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
I THINK, IN THE END, THIS COULD
HELP HER MORE THAN SOME OF THE
ALTERNATIVES, ALTHOUGH IT IS
STILL A SCATHING INDICTMENT OF
HOW SHE CONDUCTED HERSELF.
>> AS YOU KNOW, THE CLINTONS
DON'T MIND.
THE CLINTON ALWAYS THINK THEY
CAN SURVIVE SCATHING.
WHAT THEY CAN'T SURVIVE IS
INDICTMENT.
SO THEY'LL TAKE SCATHING ANY DAY
OF THE WEEK.
ALL RIGHT.
MARK, I'M GONNA REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING WHAT YOU HAVE
TO SAY ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS DOWN
THERE WHEN WE NEXT SEE EACH
OTHER.
UNTIL THEN, ALL OF OUR VIEWERS,
EVERYBODY, TIM JONES HAS A GREAT
STORY ON BLOOMBERGPOLITICS.COM.
IT'S ABOUT A TOWN IN VERMONT
DEBATING WHETHER OR NOT TO ALLOW
SYRIAN REFUGEES TO RESETTLE
THERE.
TOMORROW I WILL BE IN ATLANTIC
CITY.
MARK WILL BE IN CINCINNATI WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
AFTER THAT, WE'LL BE WITH JOE
BIDEN.
COMING UP, ON "BLOOMBERG WEST,"
THE MANAGER OF LOCKHEED MARTIN'S
JUDO PROGRAM.
UNTIL TOMORROW, FOR ME IN
CHARLOTTE AND MARK IN RALEIGH,
WE SAY TO YOU SAYONARA!
♪